taking to the ice to help an injured
metro police officer tonight is the play
for shade charity hockey game inside
city national arena there's some pretty
big names that are taking part but it's
all to help a more important bigger name
and that is officer shane michelonis of
course in his recovery victoria saha is
live this morning at city national arena
with some details on the game victoria
good morning
good morning john yep officer michelonis
loves ice hockey so tonight is all about
him all the proceeds from the tickets
being sold tonight will go to help fund
his recovery officer michelonis was shot
last summer when he was responding to
protests on the las vegas strip those
injuries left him paralyzed from the
neck down and he needs constant care but
the community has been by him in his
fight to recovery joining me now is
organizer of this event mike tomka good
morning morning how are you i'm doing
really well so tell me um you know this
event has been in the works for a while
now right almost a year
we kind of lost some time because of
kelvid but it's everything has fallen
together amazing golden knights
foundation city national the ipof all
working together to make this a huge
success tonight for shay we're gonna
have some really cool t-shirts on sale
thank you our friends at threads of envy
it's the play for shea classic hopefully
we'll do it on an annual basis
raising money for a boy yeah and some
pretty other uh neat new things that are
being raffled up right yeah we have some
great gifts we have signed hockey sticks
and this amazing guinness hockey jersey
all the neighborhood restaurants and
stores have chipped in for gift cards
the community is really coming together
for this it's really sweet
great and the unl rebel hockey is
hosting this event here at city national
arena tickets are 20
the doors open at 7 30. again
puck drop starts a little bit before 8
o'clock but you can still get the
tickets here at the door
tomco says that where their goal is to
sell around 350 tickets so they're
hoping for a big turnout reporting live
victoria saha eight news now victoria
should be a great turnout there's a the
roster of players that are playing it's
the former college guys current college
players a couple of uh golden nights
members of derek england shane 90. so
it's going to be good stuff we'll catch
up with you later on this morning 608
here on a friday morning